hey everyone welcome to simply launch
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning the complete software
testing but before we begin i would like
to take a quick confirmation from the
viewers if i'm clearly audible and the
screen is visible if yes kindly type yes
in the chat section and if there are any
problems that we could rectify please do
let us know in the chat section
all right i see a lot of positive
responses from ours thank you now i
think it's clear to get started so
before we get started with software
testing i would like to tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
technologies so if you are one of those
tech geeks in a continuous hunt for
latest technological trends then
consider getting subscribed to our
youtube channel and don't forget to hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simply learn now without further
ado let's get started with the agenda
for today's session
so at first we will get started with
selenium and in selenium section we will
learn the advent of selenium then
followed by that we will understand what
exactly is selenium and the
technicalities of selenium followed by
that we will understand the selenium
tool suite then we will learn how to
install selenium in our local systems
then we will learn the selenium ide
tutorial followed by that we will get
started with selenium webdriver tutorial
so once we are done with the selenium
webdriver tutorial we will get started
with xpath and selenium webdriver
followed by that we will learn selenium
chrome driver tutorial
once we are done with the selenium
chrome driver tutorial we will get
started with test ng annotations then we
will have a head on head comparison with
selenium and qtp followed by that we
will go through selenium jobs and salary
trends in the current id industry
and finally to make things interesting
we carried out a survey on the major
testing software companies and collected
some most frequently asked interview
questions based on selenium now this
will be helpful for your software
testing career so followed by selenium
we have another tool that is j meter so
we will get started with j meter
installation then we will learn
performance testing followed by that we
will learn j meter load testing and
advancing ahead we will learn about j
meter api testing and finally in j meter
part we will learn the j meter script
recording so once we are done with the j
meter script recording and j meter tool
we will get ahead and learn the jenkins
so in jenkins part we will have a brief
tutorial about what exactly is devops
where we will understand the
fundamentals of devops so that we have a
clear idea what we are dealing with and
why we are using jenkins and software
testing followed by that we will learn
the critical part of cict pipeline then
we will get started with what is jenkins
and then we will learn how to install
jenkins in our local systems once we are
done with the installation part we will
go through continuous integrations in
collaboration with jenkins and finally
to make things interesting we are
including some most frequently asked
critical jenkins-based interview
questions
so with that we are done with the agenda
and i hope i made myself clear with the
agenda now without further ado let's get
started with the first part that is
selenium now over to our training
experts
hey there welcome into the world of
selenium if you're going to embark on a
journey of automation i promise you this
is the right place to start so let me
take you on the first lap of this
journey this is a video tutorial what is
selenium from simply learn what is in it
for you before you start understanding
any automation tool it's good to look
back into what manual testing is all
about what are its challenges and how an
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components and we
will be looking into each of them as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
understanding the advantages and
limitations of selenium and how do we
work around it selenium jobs and salary
very important isn't it you are here to
learn selenium you definitely want to
know what's the market demand on the
skill what what you will be once you are
skilled on this automation so what we
will do we will just discuss some stats
on the job market related to test
automation and selenium in particular
all right so let's get started manual
testing and its challenges what is
manual testing manual testing mainly
involves physical execution of test
cases against various application and to
do what to detect bugs and errors so as
a definition if you can say it is one of
the primitive methods of testing a
software execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of any automation
tools and can practically test any
application this could be as simple a
definition can be let's do one thing
let's take an example right before we
start understanding why what are the
challenges of manual testing and why we
have to really look into any automation
tools let's take a simple example say we
have a simple use case as a user i want
to log into my web application using
username and password a very common use
case isn't it and this is a common use
case for any kind of web application
under test now let's say for example i
have a web application here say i have
this
community.simplylearn.com for me to
actually enter into this application
what i need to do is first log into this
application so this is a simple login
page which accepts a user id or an email
id a password and you click on the login
now as a tester you would write multiple
test cases to test this use case for
example you will have multiple data test
cases like valid credentials invalid
credentials null value and so on you
will also test multiple links on this
page probably the forget password link
the sign up now so whatever links are
made available you're going to test that
then you will say it as this check box
so you will check the remember me
functionality and when you log in back
again you want to validate if all your
previous data are filled up you will
also check for error messages on an
invalid login you will do accessibility
testing you will also do a performance
on this page like say for example
response time after you click on login
button and so on so while you're doing a
manual testing literally you can do any
kind of test you want so this is what
you do in the first place and then you
start executing this test cases one by
one you will find bugs your developers
are going to fix them and you will need
to re-run all these test cases again and
again until all your bugs are fixed and
your application is ready to ship now
this is a very simple use case now let's
look at a little complex use case now
say you have an account creation form
like this so i have this online pan
application form right this is still a
simpler form i would say now look at the
amount of data you need to fill here
each and every field you need to test
and you need to test this with hundreds
of transactions because you're going to
have those kind of data sets with you
and then you're going to repeat them
again and again until you are satisfied
that your application is working as per
it is designed so now if you go back to
our presentation now this brings us to
the first demerit of the manual testing
and what it is this is very time
consuming process and hence it's going
to get very boring for any manual tester
also it is more error prone the risk of
error is pretty high why because it is
done manually and human mistakes are
bound to happen requires presence of
tester all the time since it's manual
execution tester's presence is required
all the time one needs to keep doing
manual steps over and over again and
hence he needs to be sitting in front of
his pc manual creation of logs and
repositories creating manual reports
grouping them formatting them so that
they are like a good looking reports
sending those reports manually to all
the stakeholders say collecting logs
from the various machines after you
execute the test cases consolidating all
those results and logs right creating
repositories maintaining them wow this
is a huge long list of mundane tasks one
needs to do and this you need to do a do
again and again until your testing is
completed right so this is going to be a
manual process and it's going to be very
tedious and as i said it is also error
pro limited scope the scope of manual
testing is very limited for example say
regression testing ideally you would
want to run all the test cases which you
have written but since it's a manual
process you would not have the luxury of
time to execute all of them and hence
what you do you will pick up choose your
test cases and then execute that way you
are kind of limiting the scope of
testing also say working with large
amount of data which is manually pretty
impractical what about performance
testing so you want to say collect
certain metrics on various performance
measures as a part of your performance
testing you want to simulate certain
multiple loads on your application which
is under test hence performing this
manually is definitely not feasible and
to top it all the say you're working in
an agile model where your code is being
churned out by developers say every week
testers are building their tests and
they are executing them as and when the
bills are made available to them for
testing now this happens iteratively and
hence you will need to run all the test
cases which you have created multiple
times during your development process
and doing this manually is going to
become definitely very tedious and
boring and is this really effective way
of doing it not at all so what do we do
we automate it so this tells us why we
want to automate one one is for the
faster execution two to be less error
prone and the most importantly to help
you run your test cases frequently as
many times as you want so there were
many tools available in the market today
for automation so one such tool is
selenium advent of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like rft qtp just to number few
popular ones selenium was introduced by
a gentleman called jason huggins way
back in 2004. he was an engineer at
thoughtworks he was working on a web
application which needed frequent
testing and he realized the inefficiency
manual testing his application
repeatedly so what he did was he wrote a
javascript program that automatically
controlled the browser actions and he
named it as javascript test runner he
also made this open source which later
was renamed as selenium core and this is
how selenium came into existence since
then selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool to test web application so
what is selenium selenium is the most
popular and widely used automation tool
for automating your web application it
enables us to test web application on
all kind of browsers like ie chrome
firefox safari edge opera and even the
headless browser selenium is an open
source and it's platform independent the
biggest reason why people are preferring
this tool is because it is free of cost
whereas the qtp and rft which i
mentioned earlier are the chargeable
tools selenium is also a set of tools
and libraries to facilitate automation
of web application it is not a single
tool it has multiple components in it
which we will be seeing in detail in
some time and all these tools together
they help us test the web application
you can run selenium scripts on any
platform it is platform independent as
and why it is platform independent
because it is developed in javascript
it's very common for manual testers not
to have in-depth programming knowledge
so the selenium has a record and replay
back capability and this tool is called
as selenium ide which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
then you just have to replay the script
so mainly this is used for demo purposes
because selenium itself is such a
powerful tool and it offers so rich
functionality you would want to be in a
position to take the advantage of all
its future however if you have testers
who do not have enough of programming
knowledge to start with there is still
this id which is a record replay tool
which you can use to create your test
scripts it also provides support for
different programming languages like
java python c
ruby and so on so you can literally
write your test scripts in any language
you like or which you know of so one
need not again know a complete in-depth
or an advanced knowledge of any of these
languages selenium supports different
operating systems and browsers it
supports windows max linux and say if
you want to run your test on ubuntu
machines yes that is also possible right
on any platform of your choice selenium
you can run the test cases selenium
suite of tools so now let's go little
more deeper into the selenium so as i
said it is a suite of twos and these are
the major components of the selenium
selenium ide selenium remote control
which is in short called as rc selenium
web driver and selenium grid from
selenium 3.0 version onwards you will
not find the remote control anymore
because it has been deprecated but you
still have your id webdriver and grid
components now let's take a deeper look
into each of this components and
understand how they function in this
suite of tools selenium integrated
development environment which is called
as selenium ide so it is the most
simplest tool in the suite of selenium
it's an integrated development
environment it has a record and playback
functionality and it's very very simple
and easy to use too however it is mainly
used as a prototyping and not used for
creating the actual automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitations since it's just a record
and replay tool so this ide is available
as a firefox plugin and a chrome
extension so either you can use firefox
or the chrome browser to record your
test scripts the commands created in the
scripts where you are going to record
are these commands are called selenius
commands and these are the commands
which interact with your browser you can
also write some of these commands
manually while you're recording your
scripts and we'll see how to do that
when we talk about the id in detail and
it is again a platform independent so
you can deploy id on any platform of
your choice so you can have it on your
windows linux and macros however the
only requirement is you should have
either chrome or firefox browser support
on that particular platform earlier
selenium ide was only a firefox
extension it died with the firefox
version 54 or i55 i guess so ide was not
supported from the 55 version onwards
and this was sometime during 2017.
however very recently all new brand
selenium ide has been launched by apply
tools and they have made it cross
browser that is it is available both on
chrome and firefox now so you can
install this extension as a chrome
extension or as an add-on on your
firefox browser it's a completely
revamped version which was done by apply
tools they literally rewrote the
complete code and now they have made it
available on the github under the apache
2.0 license and it also comes with many
new features now like reusability of
test cases it has a better debugging
technology now and most importantly it
supports parallel test execution it has
introduced an utility called selenium
side runner that allows your test cases
to run on any browser so you can create
your automation using your ide on chrome
or firefox however through the side
runner from your command prompt you can
execute any of your test cases on any
browser of your choice and thus by
achieving your cross browser testing you
can also run parallel testing using grid
without writing any specific code to do
this again this can be done using the
selenium site runner and having the grid
installation done so let's look at how
ide looks like and what are its
components are and how do we work with
ide let's go to the firefox browser now
and launch the ide and see how the id
looks so let me go to my firefox now on
this browser if you can see here there
is an icon here which says selenium id
and this appears after you go ahead and
install the selenium id plugin so now
i'll just go click on this and then i
already have a project created so this
is the id window which gets opened i
have a pre-recorded script here and what
the script does is i just open amazon
dot in website and i am searching for
the product iphone also i have an
assertion statement here which asserts
for the webpage title and then i am
closing the browser so let's first
execute the script and see how it works
and then we will get into the details of
what are the different components
available on this id so for me to
execute what i will do is it id has a
very beautiful feature here to control
the speed of the execution so what i'll
do is i'll reduce the speed a little bit
so that you should be able to see the
complete execution step by step now to
execute the script i'll just go here and
say run current test so this opens the
firefox window and the amazon dot in
website it should search for iphone
product now then it is going to do the
title assertion and close the process so
if you look here all the statements look
in green now so that means every step
has been executed successfully and there
are no errors so now let's look at the
components of this id so the first
component which you need to understand
is how do you record the test so there
is a start recording button made
available to you clicking on which you
can launch any website of the
application under test and you can start
recording your steps and once you have
recorded you can use this play button
which is nothing but your run current
test button to execute your test so if
you want to execute multiple tests then
you have an option to do so here which
is run alt test
this particular window what you are
seeing here right so this is the window
where you have all your commands which
gets recorded when you record your
script and these are pretty simple
commands and they're very
self-explanatory like say for example
open so it says open and the target is
amazon dot in that means it is giving
instruction to your browser to open this
particular website setting the window
size clicking on a button so this is the
search button which we have and then
typing what is the product which you are
searching for and then you have multiple
assert statements made available to you
in this id so these are all called as
the selling is command and as simple as
a close browser command and now if you
look here in this window this is log
window so every step there is a log
generated showing you the status of the
execution of that step so if at all
there is a failure you would see a red
failed mark against that particular step
and the test case will not say completed
successfully it will say the failure
occurred okay so it is very simple and a
very user friendly kind of an id so
let's go back to our presentation so we
saw the play button here and we saw how
to record it i also showed you the
commands the command window what we have
so these are the selenium commands and
then we saw the log which indicated the
execution of each of this command now
saving the script so let me go back to
the id again so once you have created
your test scripts you have run it
successfully you need to save your
project so for you to save the project
when you click on the save project every
ide project it is saved with an
extension dot sid which is nothing but
selenium id so you just go ahead and
click on save since i've already saved
this project i'm going to just say
cancel so that's the text file extension
it uses to save your project for more
details on how to use ide you can watch
our video on selenium id on
simplylearn.com selenium rc this is
selenium remote control so this was
developed by paul hammond and he
refactored the code and was also
credited with json as a co-creator of
selenium rcs used to write web
application test in different
programming language the server itself
is written in java language it's
supporters like java c
perl python and php it interacts with
the browser with the help of rc server
it uses a simple http get and post
request for communication this rc server
is also a selenium 1.0 version but it
got deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3.0 and it got
replaced by selenium webdriver we will
see why this happened when we talk about
the selenium webdriver this is the
architecture of selenium remote control
so when jason huggins introduced
selenium the tool was javascript program
and he called it as javascript
testrunner and it is also called as
selenium core so every html has this
javascript statements which are executed
by this web browser there is a
javascript engine which helps in
executing this command now this had a
major issue of something called a same
origin policy now what is the same
origin policy same origin policy
prohibits your javascript from accessing
elements or interacting with the scripts
from the domain different from where it
is launched and this was for the
security measure for example every web
page in say google.com domain like say
your search email google drive can be
accessible but nothing outside this
domain like say if you want to access
yahoo or an amazon that was not possible
due to security reasons obviously so the
testers had to install the selenium core
and the web server which contained your
web application which you are basically
testing on the same system and this was
not feasible and effective all the time
now to overcome this to overcome the
same origin policy what paul hammond did
was he created something called as this
remote server which is selenium remote
control server and it acted like a proxy
to trick the browser in believing that
your core which is your selenium core
and your web application under test are
on the same domain this thus by
eliminating your same origin policy and
this was called as your selenium remote
control which was a version one of
selenium now if you look at the simple
architecture of this what are the things
it has so one is your script right first
you need to write your scripts using any
supported language like say php java
python and ruby as i mentioned now
before we start the testing what is the
requirement of the selenium one version
is you need to install the rc server now
this rc server is a separate application
so once you install this this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
selenius commands now these are the
selenius scripts it interprets them and
it executes it on your browser and the
results are sent back to your test
scripts and this browser interaction
happens only through this rc server
again as i said using a simple http get
and post request to communicate now upon
receiving these instructions right from
the selenium core the response is sent
back to this rc server from your browser
and back to your test scripts so the
cycle starts from your test scripts the
selenius commands are interpreted by
your rc server those are sent to the
browser and it's a simple javascript
which executed on your browser and the
results after the execution are sent
back to your test scripts through your
rc server this is a simple cycle now
this cycle is repeated for every command
written in your test script until your
complete test case is executed okay so
this is how the rc worked now this rc
had few shortcomings and what are those
one is the architecture of this rc
itself was complicated why because of
this intermediate rc server which we
have between the browser and your test
script and this rc server had to be
installed before running any test
scripts so that means this became an
additional setup and it acts as a
mediator between your selenium commands
and your browser also the execution of
commands takes a very long time it is
pretty slow why because every command it
needs to make a full trip from your test
script to your rc server to the core and
to the browser execute the script and
then again back in the same line which
makes your overall test execution very
slow and now because of this short falls
webdriver was introduced so selenium
webdriver selenium web drivers were
introduced by a gentleman called styman
stevert and it was developed in the year
2006. it is the first cross-platform
testing framework it is a programming
interface to create and run test cases
it makes provision to act on web
elements so basically there are multiple
locating techniques which selenium
webdriver provides us for finding those
elements and to perform operations on
those web elements webdriver does not
require a core engine like rc and it
interacts natively with the browser
application so there's a direct
interaction with your browser
application and it eliminates the need
of having that intermediate rc server
and that makes the architecture pretty
simple this web driver again it supports
multiple languages which we already
talked about and also it has integration
with multiple frameworks so once you
understand how the web driver works what
are its functionalities and what are it
drawback webdriver or scripts we also
have a web browser here and then we have
a web driver however what we do not have
this additional server which rc required
and this makes the architecture of the
web driver simpler the browser is
controlled directly from the operating
system level now due to this direct
communication the speed of test
execution is much faster than rc now how
does this web driver work so we have
something called as client libraries or
the language bindings so we know now
that selenium supports multiple
languages and you're free to use any
supported language to create your
automation script and where are these
libraries available so if you go to
seleniumhq.org so let me go to the
browser and show you that so in the
dot r if you go to the downloads so here
you will see something called as
selenium client and web driver language
binding and depending on the language
which you want to work with or which you
want to create test scripts with you can
download this client libraries so if
you're working with java download the
client library for java so if you're
working with python you have a
corresponding link which you through
which you can download your client
libraries and then selenium provides lot
of apis for us to interact with the
browser and these are called as the rest
apis so then we have the browser drivers
through which we interact with the
browser now what are these browser
drivers so there are drivers specific to
each browser so let me show you that on
our selenium hq dot org so here if you
just scroll down you have something
called as third party drivers bindings
and plugins for every supported uh
browser of selenium you have a
corresponding driver file available now
say for example if you want to work with
firefox mozilla gecko driver is what you
need to download and these driver files
so if you go and click here you will get
an executable driver file for any of the
platforms which you're working so if
you're working on windows mac os or
linux you can just download the
corresponding driver files here so these
drivers see these driver files are the
ones which interact with the actual
browser and how does this happen this
driver establishes the connection with
the real browser without revealing the
internal logic of the browser
functionality now what does that mean
say we want to execute a test script and
how does this descript http request
which is generated and sent to this
browser driver which we just saw for
each of the command in your scripts and
then this driver receives the request
through your http server and this hp
http server does all the execution
directly on the browser and then the
execution status the complete status is
sent back to your test script so let me
show you a simple use case how it works
with the web driver so for that let's go
to my eclipse here so i already have a
test script written here in webdriver
and what this basically does is it
launches
dot
amazon.com
website it uses the firefox browser and
then i'm also printing it on the console
and then i'm closing the browser this is
a simple functionality which i'm doing
using i've already installed selenium
here and i've written a simple java
class and this java class we have
multiple methods one is to launch
browser one is to fetch close the
browser now while launching the browser
i said every so somewhere in this java
class i need to tell selenium as which
browser to use and how is that done that
is done by this first two statements
here where i am doing a system.set
property and where i am indicating that
this is my driver file which is
geckodriver to be used and using this i
want the selenium to launch the firefox
browser and after this all the
operations any operations which you want
to perform on your web application under
test you can do it here now let's go
ahead and execute this and see how it
works so simply what i need to do is
i'll just say execute this as a java
program so the firefox browser is
getting launched so you can see amazon
dot in being launched here and since we
are not doing any operations here what i
am simply doing is printing the title of
the page and closing the browser that is
it so if you see here you can see the
page title is online shopping site so
and so and this is what i'm printing
through this method which is fetch page
title a very simple way of writing a
automation script using webdriver so now
you saw how we write a small test script
using the webdriver function now say if
i want to run the script on multiple
browsers and i do not have just one test
case i say say i've got hundreds of test
cases now with this approach what you
can achieve your best is you can
sequentially execute on every browser
available and all your 100 or 200 test
cases whatever you have now this is
going to take quite a long time to
execute and hence to reduce the time
taken for the execution selenium has
something called as grid selenium grid
the main objective of the grid is to
minimize your test execution type this
grid is designed to distribute commands
to different machines simultaneously in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment for example a
web application for which say you have
automated thousands of test cases and
you want to run them as a regression
suite across multiple browsers and os
need to run them parallelly and not
really sequentially so grid allows this
parallel execution of tests on different
browsers and operating system you also
want an integration with reporting tools
so that you can get a consolidated
report after the tests have been
executed on multiple machines so grid
can be integrated with such many other
tools how does the grid work so grid has
this hub and node concept which helps in
achieving the parallel execution let's
which you're seeing here like windows
mac and linux and your requirement is to
run tests on all the supported browsers
and operating system like this one so
what you do here is you configure a
master machine that is called as
selenium standalone server and this
selenium standalone server can be
download downloaded from your selenium
hq website so let me show you that let's
go to my browser and in the downloads
here if you see selenium standalone
server version
3.1.4.5 and this is what you need to
download so using the server you create
a hub configuration like this once you
do this you also need to create nodes
specific to your requirement like a
windows 10 like a mac machine with
firefox with the windows 8 with a chrome
and mac say with safari browser and the
node configuration is also done using
the same server which is the selenium
standalone server so you create a node
configuration on this node machines so
once you have the setup created through
your master that is your hub you can
control on which nodes you want to
execute which test say for example here
say you want to run some test on your
mac machine with safari browser so you
have a kind of smoke test which you need
to run now through the master you can
control this complete execution so what
master does it it selects this
particular node depending on the
configuration which you have set on the
master machine also you could have
multiple possible combinations like say
i want to just run smoke test on all my
nodes i want to run specific component
test on say only windows 10 with an edge
browser or i can say i want to just
complete regression suite but only on
mac machine and so on and all this is
controlled through your master so what
happens on the node once it gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs the specified test on the
browser so you can check out our
detailed video on selenium grid for you
to understand how the grid works and how
do we do this configuration and execute
the test to summarize the selenium
versions selenium version 1 comprised of
an ide rc and grid as we discussed
earlier rc was on its path of
deprecation and webdriver was taking
birth so selenium 2 had an earlier
version of webdriver and also rc existed
from 3.0 onwards rc was completely
removed and web driver took its place
also there's a four dot version around
the corner it has more features and
enhancement so some of the features
which is expected are like w3c webdriver
standardization they have an improved
idea and also i believe there are some
improvements done to the grid advantages
of selenium speed and accuracy since
there is no manual execution your test
can run faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution so you can actually
execute large volume of test cases
within a short frame for example let's
say before your release of product
during your last lap of testing you find
a bug and it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and what you
want to do is you want to run all the
test cases pertaining to that area can
you imagine the amount of time which
will be required if you have to do this
manually but by automation you can
achieve this in a short duration of time
and you can also enable releasing your
product in time and with less or no
human error the second advantage is it's
an op spectrum of programming languages
it is not restricted to any particular
programming language whatever language
you are comfortable with you have an
option to use that and to write your
selenium scripts selenium has support
for almost all browsers and operating
system including a headless browser so
this helps you to create test cases once
and run them across all browsers and
operating system and thus saving your
time for manual execution it also helps
in achieving a broad test coverage it's
a pretty easy to use tool you can check
out all our videos and you can just
master the skill of writing automation
scripts reusability and add-ons of
course like any programming languages it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy limitations so
like any other tool selenium also has
certain limitations so let's look at
what they are and see if there are any
workarounds also since selenium is an
open source you do not have much
technical support available however
there are loads of documentation
materials forums available which you can
refer to this tool is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
application or desktop application
automation however what selenium
provides is a support for integrating
tools like apm tool for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing since especially it is designed
for web application automation but then
we again have many other tools which can
be integrated with selling but we
definitely need more so it provides
supports for tools like test ng report
ng extend reports which you can
integrate and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it of course it does not
have a test management capability a tool
need not have all these capabilities but
again you can integrate with the test
management tool used in your
organization since selenium supports
multiple programming language the
developer of the automation script need
to have some basic knowledge of any
programming language to write effective
automation scripts of course a deep
advanced knowledge is not required a big
solution for your automation need and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is what makes it the most popular today
most popular tool today for automation
in this video we will look at how to
install selenium on windows system
selenium installation is a three step
process so it has certain prereqs the
first prerequisite you need to have java
in your system so we will be installing
java first and then we will be working
with eclipse id so we will be installing
eclipse and then we will install
selenium for java we will install the
version java 8 and for eclipse we have a
version 4.10
this was the last stable version which
was released in december last year so
i'll be using that version and selenium
we will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the java installation so
to install java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdks and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the oracle login to that
account and then you can just download
the java it so since i already have an
account and i have already downloaded
the package but i'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this java development kit 8211 so this
is the version will be downloading it so
click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as i said i've done this i've just
created a directory called installers
and i'm going to be keeping all my
installables here so here i have a
folder called java installer and this is
where my installable is so now that we
have this file so we will just go ahead
double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can
change the directory to the choice of
whatever drive and the folder structure
you want to i would like to leave it as
default here and we'll just go and click
on next and then the java installation
is in progress so let's wait until this
is completed it really shouldn't take
too much time maybe just a few more
minutes here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we leave the destination folder
as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what i'll do is i'll go to my
command prompt and i'll send just say
java minus version so it says java
version 1.8 and this tells us that the
java is installed successfully now after
this installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configuration one is you
need to set the path variable and then
we are also going to set a java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the java got
installed was in program files java i
have there are certain previous versions
which had installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here let's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what i have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our doors i'll just copy this
path and then
go to your control panel here go to your
where is my system yeah so click on the
system go to system setting and here in
the environment variables find the path
variable okay and then say edit now what
are we doing here in the path variable
is we are going to add the java bin
directory to the path be very careful
whenever you are editing your path
variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say control v
paste the path which you have just
copied from the explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the java now
what i'll do for that is i just say new
i just type java home here
and what is the value of this we need to
set we need to set the same path but
without the bin directory so we just
need to set the path till your java
directory that is this so we'll just
copy the path again and paste it here
that is all just say okay click on ok
click on ok here and we are done so
again let's go to our command prompt so
now successfully we have installed java
on the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was 201906.
so especially with eclipse since it's an
opens and hence that is the reason why i
have picked up the version which is like
last year's version which is uh 4.10
which was released in so you can always
choose to go with the latest version but
then if there are any issues and if
you're like first time working with the
eclipse you're going to get confused as
where these issues are coming from right
so i would still recommend that you use
the last table version which is
available with your eclipse so now to
get the last table version what you need
to do is go and click on this download
packages and here if you scroll down
this page you can see here more
downloads so there is a list of all the
previous releases of to download so just
click on that 4.10 version and then
click on the os on which you want to
install eclipse for us it is windows so
i'll just click here on the 64-bit
windows and then click on the download
and you will be downloading the complete
package so once you download this is
what it will look like so let's go back
to our directory of installers so this
is the installer for the eclipse which i
got now what's the next step i need to
do just launch this installer and
install eclipse so i'll just say double
click on this i'll say run
so here you'll see multiple options here
for eclipse installation so depending on
your requirement you can go ahead and
install any of these packages so for us
we just need an eclipse id for java
developers so i'll select this and i'll
say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so i have chosen d drive here
this is the default directory name it
takes which is ok we can leave it as it
is and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
accept it okay so the installation has
been completed successfully so let's go
and click on this launch and let's see
the first window what opens
when you launch the eclipse you need to
specify a workspace directory
now what is this workspace directory so
this is a directory or a folder wherein
all the java files or any programs or
any artifacts which you are going to
create through eclipse will be stored in
this particular folder so this could be
any location on your system so this is
you can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is i'll go to the d drive and
i already have a directory so here i'll
create i'll just clear select this
folder and then create a folder my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so i'll
say file new and since i'm going to be
using java with selenium i'll say create
java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the jre which
you want to use so we just installed
this jdk 1.8 okay so i'm going to click
on use default gre otherwise you also
have an option to use a project specific
gr for example i could have two
different projects where one project i'm
going to be working with gre 1.8 and
there is another project which i want to
work with the latest java maybe java 12
and i can have more than one quiz so if
you have another java installed here it
will show up in this list so and you can
just go ahead and select that now since
we have only one java installed on our
machine which is java 1.8 i will say use
default gre which is 1.8 and i will
click on finish now if you observe this
folder structure the project which is
created see all the reference libraries
to this particular java have been
created here now we are ready to create
any kind of java programs in this
project so now we have successfully done
the second step of our installation
which is the eclipse installation after
this we need to install the selenium so
again let's go back to the browser and
see what files we need and here i will
be going to the seleniumhq.org
so if you are working with selenium this
particular website the seleniumhq.org
is going to be a bible everything and
anything related to selenium is
available in this website whether you
want to download the files whether you
want to refer to the documentation
anything regarding to selenium is
available here so what we want now is
the installables for seller name so here
go to the download tab now for you to
install sand alone selenium server so
this is not required immediately when
you get started with selenium however
when you start working with remote
selenium webdriver you would be
requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that it will download the
file into your download folder so this
is one particular file which you need to
keep next selenium client and web driver
language bindings now in today's demo we
will be looking at selenium with java so
that means my client package of java is
what i need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with it say if you're once we
are working with java you need to
download this package so simply what you
need to do click on this link and it
will download the java package for you
which are basically the jar files so we
have client libraries now and then there
is another component what we need now
with selenium you're going to be
automating your web browser applications
correct and you also want your
applications to run on multiple browsers
so that means your scripts the
automation scripts which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like edge safari chrome firefox and
other browsers even it has a support for
headless browser now every browser which
it supports comes with its own driver
files now say for example we want to say
work with firefox driver so that means
for us to start working with firefox
browser we need to download something
called as a gecko driver here and if you
want to work with chrome browser you
need to install the chrome driver so
depending on what browsers you'll be
testing with go ahead click on each of
the demo what i need to do is i just
need to click here on the latest link so
when i click on the latest link it is
going to take me to this driver files so
driver files are specific to each of the
operating system so if you go down here
you will see there is a separate driver
file available for linux for mac and for
windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file i need because
we are working on windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
seleniumhq.org
for us to install selling so let me show
you the folder where i have already
downloaded all this so if you see here
selenium java 3.141
okay this is nothing but our client
library which we saw here let's go back
to the main page here that is this so
once i download this this is a zip file
after i unzip the file this is the
folder structure i see and let's see
what is there in this folder structure
so there are two jar files here and then
in the lips there are multiple jar files
and we will need all this to work with
selenium and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what i did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser i created a directory here
called drivers and i've kept all my
browser drivers here so i have a driver
file downloaded for chrome i want to
work with firefox so i have a gecko
driver here and then for internet
explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse go to the build path and say
configure build path go to the libraries
tab here now do you see this jre
libraries here this is what got
installed first and now similarly we are
going to add the selenium jars to the
slide british and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on add external jars go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so i
have two jar files here i'll just say
click open again i will click on add
external jar now from the libs folder i
will select all this file so select all
the five just say apply and close now if
you look into your project directory
here you will see some a folder called
referenced library and this is where you
will see a very simple installation in
eclipse when you want to install
selenium you just need to export all the
jars of the selenium into eclipse and
now your system is ready to start
working with selenium scripts all right
so now let's just test our installation
by writing a small selenium test script
so for that what i will do is i'll go to
the source folder right click new and
i'll say java class so let's name this
as say first selenium test and i will
select this public static void mail and
i will click on finish all right so now
let's uh create a use case say we want
to launch a firefox browser and then we
want to launch the amazon site so these
will be just two simple things which we
will be doing in this test script so for
me to do that what i usually do is i
create a method for any functionality
which i want to create here so now i
want to do a launch browser so i'll
create a method here called launch
browser now whenever you start writing
your selenium scripts the first line
what you need to do is you need
webdriver driver so now if you hover
over this error what it is showing it
says import web driver from or dot open
qa dot selling it so if you remember
when we installed the selenium we
imported all these jars right so that
means so what whenever we want to use a
web driver we need to import this class
from these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import state done now next
step now for us to launch a firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that i'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value now what
is the key i'm going to mention here i'm
going to be mentioning the gecko driver
and the path for the gecko driver okay
because since i'm working with the
firefox so in double quotes i'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know where we have kept our driver
first let's go to that driver files in d
colon i have selenium tutorial in
installers i have driver folder okay so
i'm just going to copy the complete path
from here ctrl c and
i paste it here control v along with
this i need to provide the file name
which is
geckodriver.exe and let's complete this
step next so once i've set the property
i need to provide a command for
launching my firefox driver and how do i
do that i simply use this driver object
which i have created driver equal to
new firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for web driver
we also need to import the package for
firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
firefox with these two statements we
will be able to launch the firefox
browser and as i said in our use case
what is the next thing we want to do we
want to launch say amazon dot in website
for that there is a command in selenium
which says driver dot get and you pass
the url here so for me to write the url
what i usually do is i go to my browser
i open the website which i want to work
with in our case it's amazon dot in and
i just simply copy this fully formed url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
now this ensures that i don't make any
mistakes in typing out the url let's
complete the statement and we are done
and now in the main function i'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so i'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now i'll say obj
dot this is a function launch processor
so let's save this and execute this
control c right click run as java
application okay so the mozilla firefox
has been launched now it should launch
your amazon.com bingo so there goes our
first test script which runs
successfully in this session we will be
looking at how to install selenium on
your mac machines
selenium installation on mac is a
three-step installation
one we need to install java which is a
prereq and then we need an id to work
with so we will be installing eclipse
and then we will install selenium and
these are the versions of the installers
which we are going to use so we will be
using java 8. eclipse version 4.10 which
was released in 2018 december and then
selenium version 3.14
so let's get started with our first step
which is the java installation
so for us to install java let us go to
our browser
and simply what i'll do is i'll just
google for
java 8 download
we would select the oracle site for
downloading the sd
okay so once you go here you can see
that we have something called as java
software development kit 8 u211 so this
is the version we'll be working with so
in order for you to download you need to
have an oracle account so since i
already have one i have directly been
logged into that so if you do not have
an oracle account please go ahead create
an account for yourself so that you can
download any of the java installers
now let's go for and download our
package so i'll be downloading this
package for that i need to click on
accept license agreement
and now the download is going to start
however we will not wait for the
complete download to happen since i have
already downloaded the package and i
have kept it in one of my folders so let
me show you where that is
so let me go to my finder so what i have
done is i have created a folders called
installers and all the software which we
are going to require today for us to
work with selenium is what i have
downloaded it and kept it here so we'll
go step by step so that you understand
what each of these packages are so as
you see here i have the jdk 8 which i've
already downloaded so let's go ahead and
install jtk so how do we install jdk so
you have the dmg file here you just go
ahead and double click on that
okay and then i'll double click on this
package
and
install
so it's going to ask me for my password
okay i've given my password and i'll say
install the software
probably it will just take a couple of
minutes to install java
okay there you go so now the java has
been installed so let me close this
window let me close this window too and
then now i'll go to my terminal window
so let's open my terminal and here
let's say java minus version
bingo so there we have java 1.8
installed on our system now there are
couple of other things which you need to
do apart from installation of your jdk
you also need to set some system
variables right so in mac how do you set
the system variables or the environment
variables you do that in your bash
profile so let's see how we do that all
right so what i will do is i'll use an
editor which is my vi
okay and then i'll open my bash profile
so what is bash profile it's a config
file for your bash cell
this is mainly used to export variables
in your shell
like in windows we are going to do the
system variable setting from the
advanced setting right so similarly we
are going to do that here so i will say
vi dot bash underscore
profile so this is the file
where
i will be adding java home path
now i have other paths here already
written because i'm working with other
multiple software on this machine and
now i'll go to the end of this file and
i'll say
export
java home
equal
now what is the path we need to give for
java home we need to give the path where
the java has been installed on your
system
okay first let's go and find out that
path so let's go back to our finder
and then i have a folder called library
here so here
there is a java and then there is
something called as java virtual
machines so if you have a single java or
multiple java versions installed so all
those versions you are going to see
under this directory which is java
virtual machines and java one dot is is
what we installed just now so let me go
and open that folder there is something
called as content and then home and in
this you have your jre and home
directory so simply what i'm going to do
is i'll just go here say get info
because i want to just copy the path and
what you can do is you copy this path
okay and then go back to your shell
and here i'm going to paste this path
plus i want to till the home directory
so i'm just going to type out h ome home
that is it so you have now set your java
home environment variable so simply you
do
save the file escape colon wq and come
out of it and now what you need to do
for this batch profile are to be
activated you just exit out of this
terminal
okay close this terminal window and i'll
go ahead and open another terminal so
let me close this
info text so here let me again give java
minus version
okay so everything seems to be working
fine so this completes our java
installation now your system is ready
and you have your java up and running
other thing which you also can do is go
to your system preferences
okay here you will see this java control
panel
this is another way of finding out that
your java has been installed
successfully on the machine so you can
just open this java control panel and if
there is any settings which you want to
do here you can do it through your
control panel also
all right
let's close this
let's minimize this window
and this folder windows
so we have successfully done a step one
so what's our step two we need to go
ahead and install the eclipse now same
thing what i will do i'll go to my
browser
okay
and
now i'll open another tab here
and i'll say
eclipse download
and we'll go to this eclipse.org
now here whenever you're going to do
this installation you will see the
latest version appears here my
recommendation to you is instead of if
you're working first time instead of
working on the latest version i will do
today so for me to go to the previous
versions i just need to go here on this
download packages click on it
okay so once you click on that
on this page if you scroll down you will
see something called as more downloads
right in this you will see all the bills
of eclipse which is available all your
previous versions so since today i'll be
working with 4.10 version i will go
ahead and click on this for. this 4.10
was released last year this is 2018
december okay and now when you look at
this installer you have multiple
packages available here so depending on
your need you can choose which package
you want to work with so today for our
demo what i would be using is eclipse id
for java developers
so since we are going to be working on
mac i will go ahead and click on this
downloadable
and then i'll click on this folder
let's go to my folder
okay it's not opening so let me click
from here
and then let's go to our selenium demo
folder and in that installers okay so
now do you see this eclipse java 2018 12
are
blah blah blah dot dmg so this is the
file which we are going to be using to
install eclipse now as simple as what we
did for jdk i'm going to double click on
this and install the eclipse let's see
how the eclipse gets installed
all right so now
i'll just move this folder into
applications
done
so my eclipse is ready now so simply
let's go ahead and launch so what i'll
do i'll just simply search for that on
my system eclipse there you go and i'll
just an application downloaded from
there you see how simple the eclipse
installation is it's just downloading
the package and just installing it on
your mac machine all right when you
start the eclipse for the first time you
need to set your workspace so workspace
is place where you're going to keep all
your folders all your
java code or whatever you're going to do
in eclipse all under that particular
directory um so right now it gives me a
default directory rather what i will do
is since i have created a separate
folder for our demos i will go ahead and
select that folder which is my simply
demo
and then in this i will add
a folder called
workspace
okay so that means in this particular
location whatever files i am going to
create whatever code i'm going to write
and selenium is going to be stored at
this location and then i'll go ahead and
say launch
so it will take a minute to load your
workbench yeah there it goes so when you
launch your eclipse
right so let me just
make this window bigger the first screen
what you are going to see is the welcome
screen
just go ahead and close the welcome
screen and this is the first view of
your eclipse what you're going to get so
let all the windows which we are not
going to be working today and i just
need this main screen here
now what is the first step you're going
to do once you have the eclipse i would
go ahead and this is a first project
which is going to be created so i'll say
selenium
first project
now if you observe here
so we have a jdk already installed and
eclipse needs a jdk to work with and
what it is done while i create my new
project it has already given me the
execution jre which you already have in
the system that's why it is already
chosen java one dot it in case you have
multiple javas installed in in that case
what you can do is you can always go
here select this and select the java of
your choice so say if you have got the
latest java which is java 12 installed
on your system it will give you an
option here along with java software
eight it will give you java 12 here so
you can go ahead and select that for
this particular project that option is
also available now since we have only
one jtk installed here i will go ahead
and create this project
so i'll just click on finish and it's
going to create a projection so there
are a few default things which it grades
created one is definitely the gre system
libraries right this is what we told
eclipse when we created project that my
java is 1.8 so what it has done is it
has imported all this jar file which it
requires for our java programs to work
in our eclipse id and then src which is
your source directory wherein we will be
creating all our java code or selenium
test scripts okay good so far so this is
a simple way of installing your eclipse
and getting your eclipse ready to work
with your selenium all right so now
let's go back
so we have done the installation of java
we have done the installation of eclipse
now what's left just the selenium right
so what is that we need for selenium
let's go back to our browser
okay and this time we will go to
selenium
hq
dot org
so this is going to be a bible for you
if you're going to be working with
selenium so in this website what i do is
i go to downloads
and there are two things which we need
to download for us to work with selenium
one is the selenium standalone server
so when you are going to be working with
remote selenium webdriver is when you
would require this however i would
suggest that we download whatever is
required for us even though we might not
use it immediately so what i just need
to do is i need to click on this and
it's going to download this server for
me
so i have already downloaded it and i'll
show you that
and then what we need is the selenium
client and web driver language bindings
okay we need a client so what is the
client which you are going to work in we
are going to working with java client
with the selenium and for that i need to
go ahead and download this if you're
working on say c sharp or ruby or python
then you have the respective packages
which you can go and download now since
we are going to be working with java
here i would go ahead and click on this
and this is going to download the java
client for me now as i said since i have
already downloaded go ahead and look at
what are those downloadables what we
have so let's close out this window now
if you see here
one is the selenium server standalone
which we just downloaded and then when
you download the client libraries what
it does it it creates a zip file it
downloads a zip file and it unzips it
and what is contained in that particular
folder so if you look here selenium java
3 in this folder you have multiple java
files under the folder libs you have
other jar files now these are the files
which we will need and now let's see how
do we utilize this file in our eclipse
so for that let's go back to our eclipse
okay so let me maximize this window so
in eclipse first thing what you need to
do is click on your project
okay right click on that
and then you have something called as
build path
go to the build path and say configure
build path
now here in this configured build path
what you need to do is go to your
libraries
okay go to add external jars
now when you click on that this is where
you need to select all your jar files
from what you have downloaded
these two first
okay
then again you click on the arrows and
libs so select all the jar files in the
list
say open
you have all the java files what we need
identified here go ahead
once you do that how do you know whether
all those jars have been imported
correctly go to the reference libraries
here you should be able to see all the
selenium jars which we have downloaded
to be listed out here and so it lists
here so that means we have successfully
imported selenium to test our
installation let's go ahead and write a
small test script so for that i'll go to
my source folder
right click new and will create a java
class so let's name it
selenium
first test
and i will also use a public static word
name here and i'll click on
finish
let's remove all this comments here
which we do not need so before when we
write our first line of code first what
we need to do is create an object of
webdriver so i'll say web driver driver
okay so now if you see this error it
asks us to import this particular web
driver class from a package and that
package is org dot open qa dot selenium
okay so now you can see this import
statement
now let's go ahead and write our
test case now for this test case what we
will do is
we will simply launch a browser say
firefox browser and we will also launch
a website
now i'll create a method for that i'll
say public void
launch browser
so if previous videos on selenium
webdriver basics i have explained there
that every browser which you want to
work with in selenium comes with its own
driver and this website of selenium and
i'll show you how to do that so if we go
to that seleniumhq.org
under the downloads tab if you go down
you will see something called as third
party drivers bindings and plugins so
all the browsers supported by selenium
are listed here and their corresponding
driver files are available so now since
we are going to be working with firefox
in this demo i will go ahead and click
on this latest release of mozilla gecko
driver so gecko driver is the one which
will be using for the gecko driver
available so just scroll down and
depending on the os which you're working
with in our case it is a macros so just
click on this file and download this
file
similarly
say if you are working with the chrome
driver what you need to do is go and
select the release which you want to
work with and just download it
now i've already downloaded this file
and i'll just show you where they are
all right so in this directory which is
my installers directory i have another
directory created called as drivers and
what i do is usually i keep all my
driver files under this folder
okay so i have a chrome driver and gecko
driver already downloaded and kept here
now let us go back to our code and see
what is that we need to do to launch our
browser so there are two steps which we
need to do for that what i do is
system
dot
set property
and this accepts a key and value pair
now key for this is giver
dot
gecko
path to your gecko driver which you have
just downloaded okay let's go to my
finder so that's here so what i do is i
simply right click on this file get info
and i
go to my eclipse
paste this path here and then the file
name which is geckodriver
done so this sets a path to my gecko
driver now next step is actually
launching the web how do i do that i say
driver
equal to new
firefox driver
now we need to do the same thing again
we need to import this class box driver
all right so now with these two steps
what we do is we simply launch the
firefox browser
and then let's go ahead and also launch
a website say amazon.com so for that i
have a command called
driver.get
which accepts a url
now this url needs to be fully formed
url so for that what i do first is i go
to my any browser
i launch the amazon dot in website
okay and then i copy this complete url
go to my eclipse and just paste it here
that's it we are ready to launch the
browser and launch amazon.com so let's
quickly create a class here or object
here of this class
so selenium first test
obj equal to new selenium first test
done
and then i need to call the method
which is
launch browser
okay so now i save this file i do a
right click on this and i say run as
java application now
this should
launch our browser
okay which adjusted and then it should
take us to amazon.com bingo there goes
our first script so we have successfully
executed our first script so that means
your selenium is up and running
successfully
let's talk about automation frameworks
okay so guys to be precise with you i'll
be talking about mission framework when
we will start automation but as that's a
part of the automation
basics so i'll just give you a basic
knowledge of it that what automation
framework is and then we'll be seeing
how we'll be going to create a framework
so first of all what is automation
framework
so it's a set of protocols rules such as
coding standards
of portability maintenance
the framework provides the basis of test
automation simplifies the automation
effort so what happens actually when we
need this automation suppose
you are automating only
one functionality you have written only
one test script of course you don't
require to write an automation framework
for this
because there's only one script if there
is any there is any change comes you can
go ahead and make that very difficult to
manage them suppose in 100 test case 100
descripts there is a username
there is a password so there is a
username and password in more than 10
if that happens then and if there is any
change comes
in the password or now you may have to
go to the 10 tips script separately and
make the change which will be very
cumbersome proper okay it may be
possible that you know error or space
error may have also if i talk about what
you have done you have created your
scripts but that is keeping in mind for
windows but what if you have to run it
on linux and you'll go back on all your
scripts and make that change what if you
have written your script for firefox
browser and you may have to run it for
chrome browser then it will be difficult
to make multiple changes so it's always
suggested that you create a frame box
framework is the one which will help you
out and solve all these problems instead
of writing one thing again and again we
will write it only at one place and
reuse that again and again it will be
very easy for us to maintain it because
that your terms of framework that's in
the framework where you can make changes
very easily portability so of course you
have written out of windows and you can
run it on any other rotating system the
framework provides the basis of test
automation and simplifies the automation
effort it is actually helpful when you
have multiple scripts for multiple test
cases
so framework is very important and
that's the reason if you go and say that
you have done the automation and you
have a knowledge of automation you will
always in the basics they will always go
with the automation so it's what
automation frameworks do we have we have
linear framework we have structured
framework data driven framework keyword
driven
are multiple types of frameworks we have
what is the methodology for automation
first of all uh you know mythology means
how you decide whether you need to
automate or not so first of all you take
a decision whether this project needs to
be automated or not because that is
becoming very complex you have planned
mythology you have less resources all
those things you have less budget
because of that you thought to automate
that
when you have part of automating it what
tool do you want to use you think on
that so you pick three to four tools
it's retails
you pick three to four tools create a
proof of concept
create a proof of concept guys are you
all aware what is proof of concept poc
obey is aware of that anyone who is not
aware of that just say engineers heard
of it kushal is aware of that okay great
not created on my own yes that's
perfectly fine of course okay cigar says
no
so guys what is proof of concept is
whenever you are suppose you are
shortlisting some tools you have
multiple automation rules in the market
correct so how do you decide whether
which
is best for you of course you can go
ahead and you know take a list of tools
you can see pros and cons of those two
but those pros and cons of the tools
depending on the
blogger depending on the editor who is
writing about that particular tool
it may not be applicable it may not be
possible that those advantages or
disadvantages
are actually correctly report rules
we
develop or create a poc ready poc means
you
actually use those tools to
automate one simple
use
all three tools what you have
shortlisted
to automate a simple script and then
figure out
the
pros and cons
of that tool
based on your experience and based on
what other people say
and then you create a ppt and show it
to the management and this is the tools
we have taken up this is the poc this is
how it works this is the advantage this
is a disadvantage and then you shortlist
one tool out of it
and that's what we call test tool
acquisition and it does not like uh you
are talking and we are learning selenium
and you will go ahead and face the
reading and that's it they will accept
it no
you have to tell them that this is the
poc and this is the benefits of opting
selenium tool
and then if they are happy with that
then they will
go ahead with that they will say go away
else they may ask you to come back off
with more details and all this stuff
okay
and it becomes very difficult to you
know
impress your management
when
there is an existing tool running like
qtp is running and you wanted to
suggest then selenium tool then it
becomes very difficult because they may
say that all the other projects are
working perfectly fine with the qtp why
should we go ahead with selenium what is
the best part so that's what you need to
highlight and need to say that these are
the things which automate with fruitful
selenium you can do that so that's where
tesla acquisition comes
then you do the test planning uh that
what all test cases should be automated
and start developing your test cases or
test scripts then you execute them and
manage them then you show the result of
all those test cases and send it to all
the stakeholders then this is the
result
so in this video we will be looking in
detail about how the selenium id works
so what is selenium id selenium ide was
developed way back in 2006. it was
created to facilitate a simple record
and replay of the test automation so
record and replay tools were pretty much
invoked during this time and the main
advantage of using such tool was an
automation engineer was not really
required to know any knowledge of
programming he could just use this
record replay tool and create the
automation and this ide was available as
a firefox extension so for one to use it
you need to just go ahead and install
the extension on firefox and then use
its recording and record the steps of
your test execution it is a very simple
interface which helps in building the
automation scripts and how this works
you just need to start the recording on
id perform your test steps on the
browser and these steps gets recorded in
the script and then what you could do is
you could export the script into say a
web driver or a junit ruby or any
javascripts and then you can use it now
however the record and replay tool is
not a very powerful automation tool and
hence this ide is mainly used for
prototyping or you could say demo
purpose now since selenium webdriver
itself offers such powerful capability
of creating robust test scripts ide more
or less remains as a prototyping tool
only so in short as i said ide is a part
of overall selenium set of tools and
mainly developed to speed up the
creation of test cases and what is the
other advantage of that one need not
really have any programming knowledge to
use this tool and mainly it is used for
writing some quick test for demo
purposes advancements with the new
selenium id back in 2017 selenium id
development was completely stopped the
last supported firefox version where
this ide was available as a plugin was
firefox 54 and from 55 onwards the
complete integration point was remote or
it was completely broken however
recently apply tools help revamp much of
the selenium id code they basically
rewrote the whole ide code and then now
they have released a new version under
the apache 2.0 license and it is
completely managed by the selenium
community now let's look at some of the
features of this now traditionally the
selenium ide was only a firefox plugin
however the new ide supports both the
browsers the chrome and the firefox and
thus making it cross browser so before
even we start looking at the other
features of the selenium id i would like
to show you how do we install this
firefox plugin or the chrome extension
so for that let me go to my chrome
browser so in the chrome words browser
what i'll simply do is i'll search for
selenium id for chrome so then let's go
to this chrome.google.com
and here you will see it as an extension
selenium id so go ahead click on add to
chrome so this will add this extension
to your chrome browser so now it says
selenium id has been added to the chrome
so how do you make out if it is added so
you can see this particular icon here
which says selenium id so this is the
way you can go ahead and install it on
the chrome now on the firefox i have
already installed it since we want to
use the firefox as a browser for all the
demos in this video so here again you
can see the selenium id so if i click on
this ide it is going to open a window
for me and the first window when it
opens it says either open a new project
or open an existing project or simply
you can start recording a new test case
in which case it creates a default
project for you first so what i will do
is i'll say open an existing project and
i've already got a project created so
let me go to my folder where i have this
project so i have this project created
and i've opened it i also have a simple
test case written now what this test
case does is let me show you here it
simply goes to google.com and then here
what i'm doing is i'm searching for
selenium hq documentation and then i
click on this site which says
seleniumhq.org and docs so which should
take us to this particular website where
the documentation is available so this
is a simple script which i have tried to
write it in this id so let's keep both
this windows open and let's go back to
our presentation to see the first
feature of this selenium id the first
feature what it says is improved locator
functionality what are locators so these
are nothing but the techniques used for
locating your web elements on your
website now for example in our
example here now the type here the type
which says name equal to q so name equal
to q is a locator now this is a locator
of what initially if you saw i went to
google.com and this is the search button
which i used right the search text and
then i said enter so this is nothing but
your web element for which the locator
is name equal to q now what happens in
id is when you record it it has taken
the attribute name and it is recognized
this particular web element using this
attribute however it also has a feature
wherein it also records its multiple
locators available for that particular
web element for example it also has a
css locator it has an expat locator now
how does it help here say for example
tomorrow this particular attribute name
right for the search box if it changes
then what id does is when you execute
this